carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
reciban todos un cordial saludo desde
nuestros estudios en parís gracias por
estar una vez más en nuestra sintonía
hoy les tenemos un programa muy especial
con un recorrido por la historia el
patrimonio y la música franceses
ah
carrusel de las artes los lleva al
corazón de notre-dame de parís donde
decenas de arqueólogos rescatan de las
cenizas los restos de la catedral
devastada hace dos años
conoceremos el grabado de monedas de la
mano del artista joaquín giménez creador
de numerosas monedas y medallas entre
ellas el árbol en el reverso de los
euros franceses
y fuimos al encuentro de carmen maría
vega artista francesa nacida en
guatemala y víctima de tráfico de niños
una historia que ella cuenta en sus
canciones
[Música]
a dos años del terrible incendio que
redujo a cenizas el techo de notre-dame
de parís fuimos a las entrañas de la
famosa catedral gótica para presenciar
las tareas de recuperación de material
arqueológico los especialistas buscan
entre toneladas de escombros y polvo de
plomo para salvar todo vestigio del
templo que pueda ser estudiado o quizás
devuelto a la catedral en un futuro una
empresa titánica que presenciamos es un
reportaje exclusivo para carrusel de las
artes de luz y lilian viajes con edf y
vídeos
unos minutos de ascensor y estamos a
treinta y cinco metros de altura encima
de la nave de la catedral en lugar del
tejado destruido en el incendio se
construyó un piso temporal para proteger
las bóvedas y sacar los escombros
que tuve duro que se cayó por el
incendio todo lo que se quemó como se va
cuando pieza por pieza el metro cuadrado
por metro cuadrado para metal
la catástrofe es frágil hizo las bóvedas
que amenazan con desplomarse
es imposible usar máquinas y demasiado
peligroso poner ahí el peso de un ser
humano
trabajamos suspendidos mediante cuerdas
para estar encima de la zona sin tocarla
y sacar los escombros poco a poco todos
llevan mascarillas de ventilación
asistida para no respirar el polvo de
plomo nocivo para la salud ese plomo
proviene del tejado de noud aunque se
fundió en la tragedia
desde hace dos años en suspensión se
sacan vigas carbonizadas pedazos del
tejado y restos de gran valor histórico
y todo el material del tejado que se
convirtió en polvo con pedazos de cobre
a veces destrozos de la estructura de
madera clavos todos esos elementos
tienen una historia son pedazos de
notredame que fueron dañados o quemados
pero que consideramos como vestigios
excepcional porque es una obra
excepcional para todos vemos a parís en
360 grados que es un monumento que se
siente vivo
[Música]
en la plaza frente andando los
arqueólogos escarban los enormes sacos
de restos carbonizados y recuperar los
vestigios
un clavo como este por ejemplo clavo
forjado lo vamos a conservar lo ponemos
aquí a un lado el estudio de estos
vestigios podría revelar aspectos
desconocidos de la historia de la
catedral
aquí tenemos pequeños fragmentos de
madera que podrán ser analizados y que
nos van a dar información sobre la
variedad del árbol utilizado el clima y
la época de construcción
miles de piedras cayeron durante el
incendio de 2019
[Música]
las piedras del arco de la nave que se
derrumbaron van a dar indicaciones a los
arquitectos sobre la forma del arco tal
como lo deben restaurar o reconstituir y
es probable que algunos elementos los
que están todavía en buen estado a pesar
del incendio sean reutilizados dentro de
la catedral home & en el fondo la
catedral dos cabezas de ángel que
adornaban la clave de la bóveda
permanecieron casi intactas a pesar de
la caída se ve todavía muy bien la cara
del ángel con su pelo dorado
es una emoción particular porque parece
increíble que hayan sobrevivido decenas
de investigadores esperan ahora con
ansias estudiar esos vestigios pedazos
del reloj de los jodan fragmentos de las
campanas clavos de la edad media y
quizás algunos de estos arrestos de no
jodan se conviertan también algún día en
piezas de un museo
y muy cerca de notredame se encuentra la
institución más antigua de francia a la
moneda de parís donde se fabrican
monedas medallas y condecoraciones desde
el siglo noveno allí conocimos a joaquín
giménez quien acaba de ser nombrado
grabador general y él ha diseñado
numerosas monedas francesas y europeas y
joaquín nos recibió en su taller
[Música]
en francia el grabador general de
monedas dirige el servicio de creación
de monedas oficiales y conmemorativas
medallas y cuños de la moneda de parís
el título fue creado en 1547 por enrique
segundo de francia y hoy esa función
recae sobre el artista joaquín giménez
del campo como padre para ser grabador
de monedas o de medallas no hay una
escuela específica es un oficio que se
aprende solamente en el seno de la
moneda parís y para ello hace falta toda
una vida en el pasado la fabricación del
artesanal desde el dibujo hasta la pieza
de metal
hoy en día trabajamos con computadoras y
láser pero a pesar de eso sigue siendo
un trabajo muy manual se comienza
haciendo un dibujo que luego se esculpe
en un molde de yeso es decir que nuestro
principal instrumento de trabajo es la
mano el patrimonio de la máquina
joaquín giménez ha diseñado las monedas
de varios países y en francia su nombre
está en todos los monederos inscrito en
el árbol estrellado que adorna el
reverso de las piezas de uno y dos euros
francesas
en una moneda se cuenta una historia en
1999 diseñé este árbol para el euro
francés es un árbol con raíces cuyas
ramas y hojas se dirigen hacia las
estrellas de la unión europea es un
árbol europeo en francia el árbol es un
símbolo muy importante por ejemplo el
roble donde sandwich impartía justicia o
los árboles plantados durante la
revolución el árbol es protector un ser
viviente que no deja de crecer durante
toda su vida
las monedas y medallas grabadas por
joaquín están firmadas con su nombre y
llevan lo que se conoce en numismática
como una marca de seca
grabador general de la moneda de parís
tiene una marca de ceca es un sello que
se imprime en la moneda y que garantiza
que cada pieza salió de nuestros
talleres en una fecha precisa
mi marca es un cuadrado formado por dos
jotas mis iniciales y en el interior he
puesto la cabeza de un rinoceronte a
este animal se ha usado muchísimas veces
en la historia del arte
de hecho salvador dalí lo consideraba un
símbolo del saber lo coloqué en mi sello
para representar nuestro taller de
grabado el rinoceronte es un animal en
vías de extinción al igual que el
grabado de monedas
debemos seguir enseñando este oficio
artesanal porque es un patrimonio por
eso está en mi ser si por saxo el tambor
efe como domo de munición
no
damos paso ahora a nuestra crónica
musical con natalie olivares quien fue
el encuentro de una artista francesa
pero nacida en guatemala su nombre es
carmen maría vega y ella nos confió su
historia como víctima de tráfico de
niños algo que ha contado en sus
canciones y en un libro
[Música]
la voz de carmen maría griega la
encontramos aquí en el distrito 10 de la
capital una voz de fuego que tiene mucho
mucho mucho que contar y se la
presentamos
en esta canción niña de fuego
primero la experiencia de una ceremonia
religiosa maya que hice con rigoberta
menchú en su casa y sus dos guías
espirituales en ese momento le
preguntaron al fuego cuál era mi
elemento y al parecer mi elemento es el
fuego
niña de fuego es un niño de ojo a eso y
se refiere también a un temperamento
latino y francés que me caracteriza
un hermoso hace bueno
[Música]
la canción la niña de fuego la fide efe
es una canción clave en el disco de
carmen maría vega llamado santamaría
escrito tras la búsqueda de su madre
biológica en guatemala una historia
increíble de tráfico de niños con europa
esto resulta ser un terremoto y en sus
canciones llega revela su gran secreto
una verdad sorprendente y un vuelco en
su vida
curvas como un gran día el gran secreto
es como un castillo de naipes que se
derrumba yo creía que mi madre era una
activista que nos abandonó con
conciencia y por una causa así que de
alguna manera creí que me había salvado
la vida hay algo mágico entre comillas
al creer que mi madre era una mujer
feminista combativa la canción el gran
secreto es que descubrimos que en
américa latina y una trata de niños de
la cual yo fui víctima tras la guerra y
que duró muchísimo tiempo en guatemala
empezó durante los años 60 y pues para
mí descubrir todo esto a los 25 o 26
años un terremoto yo tenía la necesidad
de saber
de entender pues ahora entiendo no me
esperaba encontrarme con esa verdad y en
mis padres tampoco creían que todo era
legal y que si había demoras en algunos
expedientes pues era normal que se
lleven diego está nos ha conducido este
mal
[Música]
canción se llama el gran secreto y a
pesar de haber descubierto sus raíces su
madre biológica y con ella su idioma
materno
carmen marilla vega no ha podido superar
la barrera del castellano
[Música]
una especie de rechazo del espanyol no
lo puedo explicar pero es como si
estuviera una caja en mi cerebro que
dijera que no y todavía hoy para mí es
absolutamente complicado la en español
no es nada fácil y no hay rechazo mi
cultura pero ahí ya me rechazo a la
alimentación
[Música]
carmen maría vega y la historia de su
vida artística e íntima revela un
problema internacional el de los bebés
robados y vendidos
te escucha y también se lee en su libro
autobiográfico el canto de la cabra lo
son
[Música]
el canto de la cabra es donde busca
hacer referencia a tus cosas a la
tragedia griega pero también es un
personaje recurrente que está en mi
libro es el nombre de la persona que
dirigía la asociación de nuestras
adopciones ilegales
muchas gracias carmen maría por la
de vista de desgracias
gracias natal olivares y nos despedimos
de ustedes con el tema de carmen maría
vega agridulce muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
sí